Hello Freak bitches ran a park.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Good to see you brother.
Good to see you,
man.
Thanks for coming on here.
I appreciate it.
You are in the middle of the,
one of the most controversial
movies in the history of the world.
Yeah.
You are.
You play,
I play Kim Jong.
Yeah.
In the interview,
which is fucking crazy,
man.
I think it was crazy when I signed on,
I realized it was crazy.
You know,
in the midst of all that.
Yeah.
What is the verdict?
Because they say that it's not,
it's not North Korea.
Someone was saying it
was an insider at Sony.
They had it.
They had it narrowed down
to a woman who hacked it.
Read that,
you know,
I don't know.
Cause after they came out with that,
the FBI came out and said,
no,
it is North Korea.
We have a lot of information
that we haven't released,
but it is trust us.
But then,
you know,
the,
the private kind of security experts
still think it's not North Korea.
I would almost always go with private
security experts over the FBI.
Almost always.
I kind of feel like most
people now what also,
which is kind of sad,
you know,
sad for the FBI,
but I think most people
are questioning it.
Would you be willing
to go over there ever?
How well and yeah,
ever do you mean like do you
mean North Korea specifically?
Do you mean Oh yes,
very specific.
Well,
no,
not go over there.
I would never go there.
Especially if you went over there
under the guidance of Dennis Rodman.
No,
no.
I would say I wouldn't
go near Dennis Rodman
in America.
I would not go near him,
but I would not go near
North Korea at all.
I mean,
if the regime topples changes and uh,
you know,
I don't know 20 years from now,
it's the likelihood of that though.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't think it's,
I think it's possible,
but in our lifetimes I think.
But uh,
yeah,
that's the only way I'd go.
Well,
we were talking about this
before the podcast started.
The exchange flashdrives
yeah.
Back and forth to each other.
Yeah.
Like in the eye,
a huge part of
the underground economy there is,
is basically these flash drives with,
with South Korean TV shows,
movies,
American movies,
you know,
just glimpses into the outside world
that they're not supposed to see.
It's a huge underground market.
So I think,
I don't mean the people there,
especially the younger people
that they know what's going on,
you know?
And if they get caught,
not only they fucked.
Yeah.
A day if the,
well this is what I,
I've read and I don't know how it is now.
It might be even worse now for all I know.
But yeah,
if they get caught they
go to a labor camp for,
I don't know how long that,
it's like a three
generational thing there.
Their kids go to a labor there and their
parents will go like the hall family
ends up being punished for their action,
which is wild.
It's insane.
Yeah.
And when,
when we hear about like
dictatorships like that,
we always think of it that's from
like the forties like you know,
you think of it as he is,
it is from the forties that's a thing.
And it just has not changed over there.
Yeah.
I just wonder what it would take for
something like that to be toppled.
And we were also talking before the
podcast started about his uncle.
His uncle apparently was
planning some sort of a coup,
so yeah.
Killed his uncle.
Killed his uncle's sons.
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
one thing that happened when our,
when our movie was about to come
out there was like a some expert
on,
on North Korea who said
that it's important that the
elite in Pyongyang see this
movie,
especially the people in the,
the,
you know,
the government and it working
at it because it's so,
it's so they're on such shaky ground
right now that for them to see something
like this could really help in getting
something to happen over there.
This is what Sony was saying.
No,
no.
This was like a,
an expert on it.
Like some professor or
something on North Korea,
which I thought was interesting.
But yeah,
I,
that kind of blew my
mind when he said that.
Wow,
that's great.
Imagine if it did.
Imagine if that was the catalyst.
If hours are ridiculous comedy,
Seth Rogan,
James Franco movie catalyst for
overthrowing the last great communist
dictatorship.
Yeah,
I mean it's cool.
Communist dictatorship.
That's crazy.
I mean it's all,
you know,
as so much of it is,
is,
is this kind of deification,
you know,
of him and,
uh,
all of this stuff,
you know,
our movie,
but not just that,
even just glimpses into the outside world.
It just chips away at that,
you know,
and he becomes who he is,
to these people and to
other people and you know,
in the government and,
and,
and that does not help their cause,
you know,
or the government or Kim Jong Un's cause
what is the Dennis Rodman thing?
Did you research him at
all when you did this?
I did,
yeah.
I mean,
Kim Jong Goon include an his father,
Kim Jong Il when he was alive.
Huge NBA fans.
He was a huge basketball fan.
He was like a loved Michael Jordan.
And there's a story of,
of Kim Jong goons.
Supposedly he was a,
when he was a student,
he went to like an international
school in Switzerland.
And,
uh,
there are accounts of
him from other students.
He just sit in class all day and draw
doodle pictures of Michael Jordan like
literally in this class.
So like he was obsessed with
basketball and in that era,
and I think,
you know,
that bowls team was
running things at the time,
like rotten just to,
he was a huge rod and fan.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That's so crazy.
See Rodney over there
hanging out with them as so.
So did you see that at
that press conference?
No,
there's a video of like a press conference
where he's basically sitting there
with the,
with the other play,
some other players who went with him
on this trip and he's clearly drunk
and he's basically justifying his,
you know,
his actions by going over there and,
and you know,
you come in friends with this guy and
he's like trunk and this is a press
conference from Korea or from America,
I think it was in Korea that
they shot that they've shot it.
And you could see the players behind him
and they just look super uncomfortable.
Bullshit
going around like,
well,
how could you not be super
uncomfortable first of all,
but hanging out with Dennis Rodman
and make you super uncomfortable.
Yeah.
Dennis Rodman calling a press conference.
That's bad,
dude.
No worries,
man.
We kicked things off,
Randall.
We're good.
It was just,
we had to cover the interview anyway.
We had to go over all the crazy
shit that he's been going through.
Yeah.
The artist formerly known as Kim Jong Un.
Did you at any point in
time feel like you fuck
dob now,
man,
you know?
No.
This is the thing.
I wasn't like scared for my life.
Right.
For your life.
This is the thing.
There were enough people like you,
friends,
family,
people who were genuinely scared for
my life that it got me thinking like,
should I be scared for my life?
Well,
you have secret service.
We had guards at the house.
Yeah.
Sony provided US guards long.
It's like a couple of weeks.
What the fuck,
Sony and at first at first I was like,
we don't need guards series,
so we don't need guards.
They're like,
let's listen.
Let us just give you some
guard just for peace of mind.
I was like,
all right,
all right.
And then,
uh,
Wa and then one day they were just gone.
Like a few weeks later they're gone.
And I was thinking,
oh my God,
we're the guards.
I need the guards.
You know,
like,
I was just so,
you know,
I felt so protected by then when I
did it and it wouldn't have otherwise.
You know,
I just got you standing to my
friends being so concerned for me.
It just Kinda got me paranoid.
Yeah.
Did anyone contact you?
Did you get any threats
or did anybody know?
No one on Twitter,
like pretended to be from North
Korea and fucked with you?
We should have done a tool.
I,
you know,
I mean I would get like spam mail,
like I always get and I
would think twice of Ip.
Like,
wait a minute,
is this like regular spam
or is this like hacking?
So my email destroy my life spam,
you know?
Right,
right,
right.
And,
uh,
but I,
you know,
I didn't know I wouldn't ever have,
I just kind of deleted it.
Like I always do,
you know?
Yeah.
You're always uni.
I was paranoid.
Unrelated.
Yeah.
Most likely.
But I,
I,
you know,
I got paranoid.
I got paranoid after awhile and then the
movie came out and like we were talking
about earlier,
it just all died out.
Like the dust settled really quickly.
It was like crazy.
It was like the biggest news
and then all of a sudden,
I don't know.
Okay.